why do you think that the left have so
much contempt for the working class
because it's a lot easier to train a
smart dog
than a dumb dog and i'm i don't i in
general
so educated college university people
are much
more easily uh manipulated by the media
much more subservient by the media
because they've been spent all these
years training
whereas people who are intelligent but
uneducated like the working class
are much more skeptical uh if you know
if you're if you're
a factory and your boss is telling you
how you're all a big family
blah blah blah you're like sure thing
boss and you go you go to your boys and
you roll your eyes because you know he's
telling you what he wants to hear
but if you're in management you might
start to believe it so i think this kind
of
two paths to perception is a big part of
it
um i don't think the working man
correctly believes that the media uh
regards them with respect to put it
mildly well the media definitely not
right and if you have the media and
labor
saying largely the same things and this
population thinks you're a jerk and a
horrible person
well you're agreeing with everything
else i would bet that you're saying
these things behind closed doors and
they're probably right
that's a really interesting insight that
the vehicle
which used to be prized or still perhaps
is prized as the delivery mechanism for
a lot of the talking points from
politicians
the normal working class view
their interpretation of that industry at
large
is perhaps becoming so jaded that even
the association with it
is now tarnishing any potential messages
which it was
this is like being judge durian
executioner of yourself you're kind of
hamstrung by your own
situation yeah and it also it's simple
just about uh
putting food on the table this is what
happened in 1978
when thatcher was head of the tories and
she hired sachi and sachi and they had a
brilliant ad campaign with all the
the welfare cues and the slogan simply
was labor isn't working
i mean just a brilliant turn of phrase
and at a certain point
you know democracy this is the best
thing you could say about democracy
there's this
articulator like okay if there are these
two choices and this one isn't working
and i have two alternatives it's not a
hard choice i'm at the very least gonna
at least try this other one
no matter what you tell me about this
woman because as things stand now
this is not working for me now it's very
easy to make the argument that she was
very bad for the working class you know
the minors so on and so forth and many
that's a big argument to be had
but in terms of uh you know feeling this
connection
as a working man and the powers that be
i mean the tories exploited this very
well in 78 and
obviously that led to her election in
79. what do you think of the
relationship between the left
and the working class in america oh it's
it's
being gloriously bifurcated and there is
uh
uh increasing i i don't think people in
britain
understand and i as someone who's
in you know knee deep in this world have
trouble understanding
how radicalized and how quickly the
working class is in the states
and i had this tweet and i said this on
rogan that
if they started putting up guillotines
corporate journalists will be tripping
over themselves to make fun of how dull
the blades are
i think there is something meaning like
they don't realize that they're playing
with fire that
these people are really being very
radicalized
uh in very uh um dangerous ways
that they feel correctly that
uh you know the corporate media is their
enemy now when you regard someone as
your enemy
my result is i don't want to talk to
them i don't want to deal with them
but it's very dangerous when a lot of
people
identify another group as the enemy and
someone's going to get ideas and that is
something i'm very very concerned about
something i'm warning against but
they're sitting in their
offices well now in their homes thanks
to kovid
and are like hahaha look at these idiots
you know putting up these
uh um uh um gallows it's like you guys
this if you talk and the left knows this
historically
when you have when you marginalize a
person or a group and they have nothing
to lose and you keep poking them
what do you think is going to happen
it's going to end up in it's going to
blow up in ways
no one wants and i'm very very concerned
about this what do you think happens
roll the clock forward
i i don't even want to speculate because
this is the kind of thing where it's
like tinder boxes you know like you like
that match and
uh violence sings its own song and i i
am desperately hoping we do not reach
that point
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace